President Trump says he wants the Russia
investigation to have a truly honest
outcome he ridiculed the probe and
criticized his opponents at a rally in
West Virginia just last night the reason
why Democrats only talk about the
totally made-up Russia story is because
they have no message no agenda and no
vision have you seen any Russians in
West Virginia or Ohio or Pennsylvania
there any Russians here tonight any
Russians they can't beat us at the
voting booths so they're trying to cheat
you out of the future and the future
that you want CBS News chief Washington
correspondent and Face the Nation anchor
John Dickerson is with us now from
Washington John good morning the
president's own lawyers described this a
standard operating procedure is
impaneling a grand jury just that well
it is that but it can be a whole lot
more you know what this really means is
it doesn't mean that the president is in
any new danger it doesn't necessarily
even mean that the grand jury or the
that they're gonna be indictments about
anybody in his first circle but what it
does mean is the administration is going
to wear this heavy coat of having daily
disclosures a news about the grand jury
and who may or may not be meeting in it
it's gonna wear that heavy coat for many
more months and that's both a
distraction it's then an invitation for
the president to react in his colorful
way and as we get into the election year
next year it's more challenges for
Republicans if there is continued talk
about a grand jury and who's appearing
before it and what may or may not be
learned there John can we ask you about
these leaked phone conversations between
the president and Turnbull of Australia
and also Enrique Pena Nieto of Mexico
I think this strikes a lot of people as
a big deal when when conversations
between foreign leaders which are
supposed to be private get leaked and
that's out there what do you make of
this and and well foreign leaders stop
calling the White House
or Washington in general if they if they
think it's gonna be out there it is it
is a big deal because presidents should
be able to have these conversations in a
free and open way so much of public life
is constrained by the fact that
everybody is watching in every possible
minute makes it very hard to get any
business done and so to just to have
these kinds of transcripts out there is
is really terrible it's probably
breaking the law but also you know it's
a sign in this administration that
somebody wants to do the president harm
I mean or embarrass him anyway now there
have been lots and lots of leaks but
this one is of a different order and it
means despite the fact that they've
gotten rid of a lot of people at the
White House and there's been a kind of
hunt for leakers that this is still
going on so it's a bad internal thing
for the White House as well to have
people in the system doing things like
this that are really aimed just at
embarrassing the president john front
page of the New York Times former
general taking control at the White
House it says mr. Kelley cuts off
rambling advisers mid-sentence he
listens in on conversations between
cabinet secretaries and the president
he's booted out lingering staff members
will these changes have an effect on
what we've seen so far well they should
because they are bringing the
administration in line with what is
essentially the practices that previous
chiefs of staff have learned over time
work in a White House HR Haldeman who is
chief of staff than Nixon basically
wrote memos saying do all of this stuff
before the Nixon administration so it's
a you know they're behind the times a
bit at the White House to be in putting
this kind of discipline in place but it
should help because the presidency is
not a place of improvisation and if
you're gonna have an improvisational
president and everybody else has to be
working absolutely in sync with each
other and that appears to be what Chiefs
of Staff Kelley is doing John quickly
there were two bipartisan bills
introduced yesterday to try to make it
hard for the President to fire special
counsel robert muller will these pass i
don't know if they'll pass but they are
an interesting development here we see
this move by congress essentially to
rein in the president to take what used
to be kind of norms
Stander's the standards that no
president would cross and try to
basically codify them into law we saw
the way the Congress do this on these
Russian sanctions this week we're seeing
him do it on health care too so this is
Congress asserting itself with the
president who has shown a willingness to
kind of cross some some traditional
boundaries
John Dickerson thank you very much we'll
see you on Sunday because on Face the
Nation John talks with Republican Ohio
Governor John Kasich and Democratic
Colorado Governor John Hickenlooper
about their two-party approach to health
care plus Republican Senator Tom cotton
of Arkansas and former Homeland Security
Secretary jeh Johnson that is Sunday
here on CBS